I'm sure you've heard all about horse
balls at this point but as it turns out
horses play a much bigger role in Red
Dead Redemption too than you might think
so much so that it can be overwhelming
if you haven't been paying close
attention to the tutorial messages I'm
gonna try to answer all your horse
related questions in this spoiler free
video so let's start from the beginning
horse controls are relatively simple
depending on what console you're playing
on tap a or X repeatedly to speed up and
r1 or RB to slow down you can double tap
and hold X or a to match a companion
speed and if you tap a or X and rhythm
with your horses gallop you will
conserve stamina as you ride your horse
you'll want to keep an eye on it scores
the heart is the health obviously and
the lightning bolt is stamina the more
you push your horse the quicker the
stamina bar will deplete and if you
don't feed your horse every now and then
or let it rest its core will drain and
it won't have as much stamina or health
meaning this will happen as you ride
feed and clean your horse your bond will
strengthen and as that bond grows you're
worse will learn advanced maneuvers at
level 2 you can rear your horse back by
pressing r1 or RB with square or X I
haven't really found a use for this
other than to look threatening from time
to time at level 3 you learn how to skip
[Music]
while sprinting press r1 or RB and you
can either bring your horse to a halt
or change directions at a moment's
notice finally at level 4 you learn how
to drift in piaf which is a fancy word
for strafe as your bond increases your
horse will also respond to your call
from greater and greater distances and
its stats including speed will also get
a slight bump if you want to see how
close your horse is to the next level
you can check the player menu when you
hit start however if you want to get the
most out of your horse you want to stop
at a stable and upgraded saddle most
items for sale are cosmetics however
there are a few things that can improve
your horse - stats like the stirrups and
the saddles themselves but wait you say
I can't seem to enter the stable and I
can't find a stupid brush to clean my
horse well that probably means you're
screwing off too much and not doing
story missions
once you complete an early mission
called exit pursued by a bruised ego you
will have access to stables across the
map and you will get a nifty brush while
at the stables you can also rename sell
and buy horses you can sell both stolen
horses and horses you've acquired
legally stolen horses won't fetch as
good of a price at stables but at a
certain point the story you will meet
some characters willing to purchase
stolen horses for a better profit heard
you paid good prices for horses level
for horses will also fetch a higher
price so if you plan on flipping a horse
I'd recommend leveling it up first
if you are looking to buy a horse the
first thing you'll probably notice is
that good horses and cheap as much as I
love tiny here he's not exactly the
powerhouse you want by your side
throughout the entire game and if the
best horses are too expensive I guess
that means we'll have to break them
ourselves lucky for you one of the best
horses in the game can be acquired for
free at the beginning of chapter two and
onward but before we get to that let's
learn how to break a horse as you
explore the world you'll find horses
everywhere big horses little horses
painted horses black horses and so on
there are a dozen different breeds
roaming the frontier all with unique
stats and attributes if you see a horse
you're interested in first take out your
binoculars once you study the horse you
will be given a prompt to show info hit
that and you can check out the horses
stats and its breed
details now there are two ways to go
about breaking a horse you can chase it
down lasso it and hop on its back or you
can approach it slowly calming it if it
gets spooked once you get close enough
you can hop on based on my extensive
research I can say with confidence that
it's much easier to break a horse if you
approach it slowly once you're on it
pull back the left stick and subtly tilt
the right stick to balance wall calming
it with square or X if it bucks you
which it probably will at first chase it
down when it calms down a bit you can
repeat the process also be mindful of
its friends
once you feel comfortable breaking
horses pack yourself some warm clothes
and head up to the Grizzlies right next
to this Lake a white coat Arabian spawns
it can be a slippery bastard but it's
well worth the effort if it bucks you
and escapes well it's gonna be a while
before another one responds so I
wouldn't wait around once you do break
it put a saddle on it and take it to the
nearest stable technically the horse
will be yours once you put the saddle on
but I like to take it back to the stable
just in case there are two other
extremely rare wild horses you can break
but finding them takes a bit longer so
maybe we'll save that for another video
a couple more things to note before I
close out this video if your horse gets
too dirty its meters will drain 25%
quicker you can clean it with your brush
or by riding it through clean water you
can expedite bonding by petting your
horse and feeding it treats your horses
cores will refill if you sleep and the
stronger your bond is with a horse the
longer it will take to bleed out if it
gets knocked down
a level four horse will take sixty
minutes before it dies giving you plenty
of time to get to town and purchase a
horse survivor good luck out there in
the wild and remember whether you're an
honorable gunslinger or a dishonorable
outlaw you should always pet your loyal
horse from time to time if you want more
Red Dead to content you should check out
our new show dirty RT where we see how
disgusting we can make Arthur Morgan
thank you for watching all right I guess
I didn't quite fit under there